it's a Hobbesian war of all against all
as CNN and Fox News do battle trump
fulminate over immigration and Hamas
makes its move I'm Ben Shapiro and this
is the Ben Shapiro show all right so we
have a lot to get to today big show
coming up we're going to talk about the
continuing attempt to boycott Laura
Ingraham show the blowback that is going
to be unleashed on CNN and MSNBC if this
continues we're going to talk about
Trump on daca we're going to talk about
the media wars apparently Sinclair
broadcasting did something so horribly
egregious the entire media is a twitter
/ it will talk about all of those things
plus later in the show I'm gonna do an
interview with the producer on the new
fantastic film Chappaquiddick which I
have a lot to say talk about a little
bit later in the show but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
upside so let me ask you this how many
times you've been on a trip and suddenly
something goes wrong you don't know who
to turn to
because you booked through some sort of
travel site and there's no one on the
other end of the phone well that will
never happen when you use up side calm
when you go to up side calm up side is
your Mission Control right you're up
there in space you know what you're
doing but there's somebody on the ground
helping direct you upside is that group
of people they have a team of
specialists working 24/7 to make sure
your flight hotel and car rental all go
off without a hitch they monitor your
trip around the clock they proactively
keep you posted on everything from if
it's gonna rain to alternative flights
home in case you want to change the time
have you ever experienced that level of
service before in any of these other
sites the answer is no of course you
haven't I've tried all these sites and I
promise you there's nothing worse than
your trip going wrong in the middle of a
trip and there's no one to talk to and
even if you go to the airline they say
oops it's too late you booked through
another travel site so you're screwed
that's no longer going to happen when
yous upside calm for easy booking
competitive prices and a team that
always has your back go to upside calm /
pen to book your next business trip
again sign up today for your free
accounts and get a free pair of Bose
headphones on your first business trips
you get that as well it's pretty awesome
deal that's upside calm / been again
upside calm / been when you do you get a
a free pair of Bose headphones on your
first business trip $600 minimum
purchase required within 90 days see the
site for complete details check it out
again upside calm and /ban they are your
mission control for travel alright so we
begin today with the update on
everything that has been going on
regarding Laura Ingraham and the
aftermath of a power clinch shooting
which is now six weeks ago but the media
have been all over it since then pushing
the gun control agenda I want to begin
by pointing out that the media's agenda
here is absolutely clear the media is
using the parkland shooting as a crutch
as a lever in order to push gun control
and in order to attack their political
opponents and really it's more than flat
the latter than the former it's not even
about pushing gun control so much as
castigating anyone they don't like
castigating anyone with whom they
disagree as a bad human being this is
what the media are into the media will
want to make it seem like if you
disagree with them on gun control this
makes you a bad person they're actually
not that interested in gun control
legislation actually getting passed
because if they were they would stop
browbeating people like Marco Rubio
senator from Florida who's been working
with Bill Nelson a Democrat senator from
Florida to push legislation they would
stop ripping on Republicans as uncaring
unfeeling monsters with blood on their
hands the media are interested in one
thing and one thing only in the
aftermath of parkland and that is
pushing the gun control narrative
specifically so they can push their more
important primary narrative the gun
control they're under the secondary the
primary narrative is that you are a bad
person if you like guns you are a bad
person if you're Pro Second Amendment
okay this is their agenda how can you
tell this is their agenda because even
other left-wing agenda points go by the
wayside if it doesn't serve the primary
agenda so here's what I mean by that
there's a whole group of students over
at Parkland or even further the left
then the group of students you've seen
on TV the EMA Gonzalez's and the david
hogs and the cameron cass keys there's a
whole group of students that are even
more to the left
but you never see them on TV why don't
you see those left wing students on TV
after all the media is full of leftist
the answer is because these students are
not serving the left-wing agenda of
pushing gun control and therefore they
are not pushing the broader left-wing
agenda of making those of us who are
anti gun control look like bad people so
here are some of the kids who have been
talking but not being heard there's some
black students over at Stoneman Douglas
who are being completely ignored by the
media you've never seen any of these
folks on TV you've never heard of any of
these people but here they were and the
agenda they're pushing is that they
don't want more school safety officers
in school because they're afraid that
that's going to lead to more arrests of
black kids so here is them talking about
this the black lives matter movement has
been addressing this topic since the
murder of Trayvon Martin in 2012 yet we
have never seen this kind of support for
our cause and we surely do not feel that
the lives or voices of minorities are
valued as much as those of our way
counterparts I am here today with my
classmates because we have been sorely
underrepresented and in some cases
misrepresented dr. Rosalind Osgood is a
school board member in Broward County
she helped these students organize and
help them get the media's attention and
let's find means and most of making
their voice available so that they can
be heard ok so we can stop it there but
these people were not heard right you're
not you're not hearing from any of these
students right there this appears maybe
a little bit in local media maybe for
brief seconds in national media and then
it goes away why wouldn't this be the
intersectional moment wouldn't this be
the intersectional talking point
remember the left's ideology is
intersectional they believe that you can
judge someone's opinion and the value of
their opinion simply by looking at the
group identity simply by looking at the
group to which they belong so these are
black students that means that their
opinions should be held in higher esteem
than the white students like David hog
right otherwise you're just exacerbating
white privilege but the media aren't
focusing on these black students
why aren't they focusing on these black
students because these black students do
not serve their agenda if these black
students were out there front and center
calling for gun control and suggesting
that everyone who didn't like gun
control as bad person the media would
have them on every single day so this is
why when people say they are
intersectional leftist what they really
mean is they're leftists first an
intersectional second intersectionality
that that identity politics philosophy
that philosophy that we can judge you as
an individual by your group identity and
your viewpoints value by a group
identity that's only important to the
left when it serves the purpose of the
left Clarence Thomas isn't too legit
black man according to the left because
his intersectional experiences as a
black man don't count because he doesn't
agree with the left well the same thing
is true of these students they don't
they're not forwarding the left hardcore
agenda and that means that their black
skin no longer counts in the
intersectional hierarchy because they're
just not that important which shows you
that all the members of the
intersectional hierarchy all the members
of this intersectional coalition who are
supposedly going to get together and rip
down the system it's really far less
about mutual respect for ethnicity and
much more about mobilizing to defeat the
supposed patriarchy to defeat the white
privilege system and that's why the
media can safely ignore these black kids
and pretend like nothing is happening
with them these doesn't serve their
higher agenda well what does serve their
higher
right now it serves their higher agenda
is using gun control to push for
boycotts against media figures they
don't like so this is a continuation of
what happened last week Laura Ingraham
the Fox News host she was boycotted not
even really boycott there's an astroturf
the boycott attempt by david hog who's a
student at still Marjory Stoneman
Douglas and he was present when the
shooting happened and he's obviously put
all over the media you've seen him
saying really vile things about people
he disagrees with saying their blood on
their hands saying that Marco Rubio's
murderer who basically took one dollar
and five cents from the NRA for every
floor to students and all the rest
well David hog he was interviewed by TMZ
after visiting some colleges and he was
asked how the college admissions stuff
was going and he said well you know to
be honest with you an ink on that great
there are four colleges that didn't let
me in and I understand there are a lot
of people who can fill those slots but
if the colleges want to help us out they
can help us out if they don't want to
help us out they don't want to help us
out well this prompted Laura Ingraham to
tweet out and he was whining about his
college admissions was that ill-advised
yes this is something I would have
recommended saying no so I think that we
should attack the perspectives that are
wrong yes I think we should attack the
people expressing those perspectives not
really but Laura says all of this and
then hogs response is not well Laura
that was kind of a jerky thing to say
his response is directly from the Media
Matters playbook Media Matters if you
don't know it's left-wing group
co-founded essentially by Hillary
Clinton and that group has been designed
for literally a decade and a half to
launch astroturf boycotts against major
right-wing media figures people like
Rush Limbaugh and Sean Hannity and Bill
O'Reilly and now against the Laura
Ingraham and so this student David hog
immediately comes forward with a list of
the advertisers on Laura Ingraham show
and within minutes he's got a list
amazing amazing how how how that worked
it's just incredible and then all of
these advertisers start dropping Laura's
show because they don't want the
blowback because here's the dirty little
secret about a lot of advertisers
they're more afraid of the blowback than
they are interested in experiencing the
the pleasure of advertising on a given
show when an advertiser advertises on a
show usually what they're looking for is
an outlet to speak to a vast group of
people what they don't want is bad
publicity so even the merest sign of bad
publicity for a lot of advertisers is
toxic and a lot of them run away and so
Laura Ingraham apologizes and david
huggins i'm not going to accept the
apology I'm still gonna push forward
with the boycott
and the media are giddy over this
because finally they have a kid that
they can stand behind and this kid is
unattackable right you're not supposed
to say anything bad about him even about
his perspective you're not even supposed
to say he says immoral things because
that would be attacking him and there's
this according to the folks in the media
right brian Stelter on CNN said he does
not ask people like david hog questions
when they say things that are absolutely
unacceptable because that would be
somehow impugning their dignity or honor
I think Brian tries but I think I was a
pretty telling statement hey David hog
is being used as a shield by the media
in order so they can push the sword at
their political enemies like Fox News
and Laura Ingraham so hog of course is
really excited about this and he's gonna
become the boycott leader of the left
and left his happy to using this way he
says that corporate America is standing
with him here's here's him making the
statement to allison Cammarata who by
the way last week said that what college
wouldn't know what college wouldn't let
someone like you in - david hog well
david hog wasn't led into some of the
colleges on the west coast because his
SAT scores weren't high enough i mean
all of the all of his admissions were
done months ago before any of this
happened
and his SAT scores apparently according
to david hager like a twelve seventy
which is a fine SAT score but that's a
hundred points below the average at UCLA
so he wouldn't expect to get into UCLA
in any case here's allison Camerata
and david hog you know making out on
national TV or you know her elise
plastering her lips to his but i think
it's great that corporate america is
standing with me and the rest of my
friends because when you come against
any one of us whether it be me or
anybody else
you're coming against all of us and i
think it's important that we stand
together it's both corporate and civic
america to take action against these
people and show them that they cannot
push us around especially when we're all
we're trying to do here is save lives
okay well that's all he's trying to it
forget all the things that he said that
are terrible about people calling daniel
ash a murderer and somebody doesn't care
about her children and saying the same
thing about marco rubio and allison
camera are just sitting there nodding
through this whole thing corporate
america is not standing with david hog
corporate america is standing with non
controversy and this is the truth about
corporate america they don't want
controversy which is understandable if
you run a business and you are selling a
sleep aid and you are on the show and
the show starts to become very
controversial and suddenly your sleep
aid is popping up in all the ads you're
afraid to the ball back and so maybe you
pull your advertisements the left knows
this and that's why they're pushing it
and so david
to push this even further he says listen
I understand that Laura Ingraham
apologized to me and I don't accept her
apology but she shouldn't just stop
there she should also apologize again on
CNN and of course on Siena and then he
says you know what else I would really
appreciate if she would apologize to
LeBron James while LeBron James okay
because a month before this shooting
happened in parkland she said to LeBron
James that he shut up in trouble we call
it we talked about on the show it wasn't
something that I was fond of her saying
in fact I criticized her saying it but
David hog is now going to be the apology
police
he's the civility police right this guy
who goes around saying that you have
blood on your hands if you disagree with
him this is captain civility now
according to the members of the
mainstream media Kerry is explaining
that that Laura Ingraham should
apologize to LeBron James - or something
there have been multiple instances
throughout Ingram's professional career
where she's tried calling out people for
example at Dartmouth University because
of their sexual orientation and she told
LeBron James to shut up and dribble I
don't see any apology for those people I
mean why it's just it's really sad it's
disturbing it was stop whatever whatever
okay it's just absurd
why should she apologize to david hager
if he's not going to accept it and then
why is he calling on her to apologize to
other people if he says the apologies
mean nothing none of this makes any
sense except insofar as the media are
happy to watch David hog go out there
and call for boycotts because they want
FoxNews boycotted they're a competitor
and then they want people and then they
are they are firmly convinced that you
cannot attack anything that David hog
says again David hug seems like a smart
kid
David hog seems like a politically wily
player that doesn't mean everything that
he says is moral or decent in fact I
think a large percentage of what he says
is immoral and indecent okay before I go
any further I'm gonna show you what
CNN's real agenda here is first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
Zeile so you want to know the only thing
better than getting a massage getting a
massage inside your own home whether
your back hurts from running after the
kids or your muscles are sore from
working out or you're stressed after a
long day of work zeal brings you
same-day in-home massages with the best
licensed and vetted massage therapist
right to your home so I've used it for
myself I've gotten zero massages for my
wife I've got it for my father my mother
and my mother-in-law I've gotten Zeile
massages for my sister the reason for
this is because it is so convenient it
is so easy before we use eel there was a
masseuse than my family regularly used
and the problem was you had to set an
appointment with her weeks in advance it
was really expensive and then you had to
drive out to the middle of nowhere
get the massage well now Zeile makes it
clear that you don't have to do this
anymore
ze al.com L'Orange eels iPhone or
Android app ze Elcom and you can select
from top local licensed pre-screened
massage therapists choose your favourite
technique gender preference time and
location for your massage and zeal we'll
send one of their 10,000 licensed
massage therapists with a massage table
music and supplies to give you that
five-star massage scheduling booking
payment fast and easy even the tip is
included 7 days a week 365 days a year
Azul massage therapist can be at your
door and as little as an hour privacy
convenience quality comfort all in your
home there's a reason it was featured in
The Wall Street Journal the New York
Times Vogue Good Morning America there
on demand they'll be at your house and
they will be the best massage that you
can get at a moment's notice it's just
fantastic
EEE Elcom and when you use promo code
bend you get twenty five bucks off your
first massage with promo code been ze
al.com or on their iPhone or Android app
again you get that special offer promo
code been 25 bucks off your first
in-home massage ze e Elcom promo code
then go ahead and check it out okay so
as I say a lot of the media are very
excited about the boycott against Ingram
you can see this on a CNN panel right so
CNN says that they have a panel and all
of these people agree how is it even
possible that Laura Ingram has a show
how is it possible that Laura has a show
well she has a show because there a lot
of people who want to listen to her but
this is the real goal here right the
real goal here is knocking Ingram off
the air just as the real goal was
knocking Shawn off the air and knocking
rush off the air and knocking all of
these various folks off of Fox News the
entire goal of the left here is to
pretend that something truly egregious
happens even when nothing truly
egregious happens now sometimes
something truly egregious has happened
sometimes there's a multi-million dollar
sexual harassment settlement for example
against a particular host and
advertisers don't want to associate with
that but that's a genuine move by
advertisers right here what we have is
an intimidation campaign by left-wing
media sources propping up a parkland
survivor for political gain and then
using that kid as a club to wield
against their own political opponents
it's really stomach-churning stuff
here's the CNN panel saying they can't
believe Ingraham has a show they want
her to private of the show obviously we
so seldom see people acknowledge that
they did something wrong she did she
said she said that she she wishes she
hadn't done it so Jake I stood on I
can't believe Laura Ingraham actually
has a show so like I'm
kind of had a point where I I'm there
she apologized look you know in with
free speech in this country also comes
consequence you have the right to say
anything you want to say but it also are
consequences to those actions and so
those advertisers are pulling out and I
think rightfully so and I don't think
she'll be back on TV after this
pre-planned vacation okay let's be clear
about this she has a pre-planned
vacation this week she will be back on
TV because this is not going to stand
Fox News viewers are not going to be
cool with Laura and Romi now stood over
Ward is by Twitter standards a very very
mild tweet it's not something I would
have tweeted it's not something I think
was a good idea but come on I mean
you're gonna end somebody's TV career
over that good luck with that good luck
with that and again I think the media is
in for a rude awakening because things
are gonna get really ugly on the other
end of this the me it's getting like for
example I think CNN is beginning to
realize this let's take let's take a
quick example let's begin with John Wall
so John Walsh is a contributor on CNN
and she says a lot of egregious things
on a fairly regular basis she's featured
very often in the things I hate segments
so Joan Walsh tweeted out a series of
attacks on Kyle cashew when Kyle cashew
is the is one of the Parkland survivors
and there are a bunch of people who
decided to attack cashew on Twitter
among them was Fred Guttenberg whose
daughter was killed in the attack Kyle
had tweeted out something like this
entire thing has become really
politicized and is no longer about
saving lives and Fred Guttenberg whose
daughter died in the attack season oh no
it's all about saving lives
well obviously Kyle wasn't talking to
him I was talking to David hog and the
rest of the parkland survivors who have
been on TV routinely pushing gun control
he was saying that the astroturfed
boycott against Laura Ingraham is not
about saving lives is obviously about
political gain well Joan Walsh liked all
of these tweets right Joan Walsh liked
all of these tweets and then Kyle
captured responded just so everyone
knows CNN would never take a side and
then he tweeted you at Joe and wash and
Walsh responded by insulting him saying
good luck handling your stress so let's
use the left standard here for a second
right let's Italy he said Wow Kyle
Kashyap are you really policing are you
really policing the likes of a grieving
Parkland father who lost his daughter
good luck handling his stress Kyle
that's what Joan Walsh tweeted out hey
can you imagine if this were Reverse for
a second imagine if I tweeted at David
Hogg good luck handling your stress
David
okay the boycotts would be giving it
right I mean this would beat you this
would be an attack on him well now you
have Joanne will also see a nun
contributor who's attacking Kyle Kashyap
and nothing no boycotts no nothing well
so here are the list of CNN's
advertisers you want to play this game
if people really want to play this game
we can play this game
maybe we can boycott CNN's advertisers
they are there for everyone to see we
can see all of the various advertisers
hey they're top advertisers in February
2018 or a Tesla t-mobile Geico
progressive Chimaera Nutrisystem BMW
Nord VPN AT&T and good good rx okay
those were their top advertisers so
should be boycotted all of those I'm not
saying we should I don't think we should
I think it's really bad for discourse in
America when we astroturf boycotts
against advertisers based on a fake
outrage
hey Beck I'm a based on a level of
outrage that is completely
disproportionate to the crime that has
been committed so I think that Joan
Walsh is terrible horrible crime here is
really so terrible in horrible no I
don't I think Joan Walsh is obnoxious so
I think CNN's the advertisers ought to
pay monetarily for something Joan Walsh
said that's dumb on Twitter no I don't
and she hasn't even apologized hey Laura
Ingraham apologized and people on the
Left are still trying to push her out
it's really gross brian Stelter good for
him he acknowledged this yesterday he
essentially acknowledged that we cannot
have a functional media system and meet
functional media ecosystem if we're all
gonna boycott each other's advertisers
based on basic political disagreements
David Ehrlich our ad boycotts the right
answer here I'm personally pretty wary
of this I think it's dangerous to see
these ad boycott attempts happening a
more and more more and more often in
this country my view is let's not shut
down any one's right to speak let's meet
their comments with more speech let's
try to try to respond that way what is
your view of these ad boycotts okay so
that that's the point that's that on you
don't need the rest of this but what
Stelter says there is exactly right
when Stelter says listen if you don't
like what laura ingraham is saying you
have a very simple solution turn off
your TV if you don't like what brian
Stelter is saying very simple solution
turn off your TV you don't like when
Joanne Walsh was saying turn off your TV
turn off your Twitter it's really
unfollow her blocker he can do all of
these things in a free country you as a
viewer have the capacity to choose what
it is you want to watch there are very
few instances when an advertiser
deserves to be hit for advertising on a
pro
Grahame usually it's when something so
blatantly egregious and awful is done or
said that the advertiser themself would
pull out anyway because the ratings
would drop anyway I'm not a big fan of
secondary boycotts especially because
they are easily astroturf because
advertisers are afraid of controversy
and folks who are politically motivated
know that so if the left wants to play
the game this game the right can play
this game too and we'll see if CNN likes
it as well as MSNBC
and we'll see if both of them like it as
well as Fox News because otherwise what
we are watching here is a pure political
hit done by certain networks against
other networks for a political purpose
that's all that's happening here and
it's pretty incredible it meanwhile
speaking of pure political hits there's
a lot of weird talk over the weekend
about something that happened on
Sinclair broadcasting so Sinclair
broadcasting has brought up all these
local affiliates all over the country
David like 173 local affiliates all over
the country and some of these affiliates
all of these affiliates had their
anchors read the same message and in a
second I'm going to tell you what are
the messages that those affiliates were
reading because the left went totally
crazy over this the media went totally
nuts over it first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at legacy box
so this service legacy box I think it's
really one of the most important things
that you can do we've done it in my
family and it's really meaningful and
it's really worthwhile here's what it is
legacy box is a simple and affordable
way to get your recorded moments
digitally preserved on DVD or thumb
drive so you load your legacy box with
your old tapes films pictures audio
recordings and then you send it back to
them and in a couple of weeks you get
all of it back on DVD or on a thumb
drive so instead of you having these
boxes full of old pictures that are
moldering in the garage instead now
you've got it right next to your
computer you can pop it in look at those
pictures anytime you got a DVD on your
shelf it's accessible it's easy if God
there's a flood or a fire you don't have
to worry about losing all your memories
you just grab the thumbs stick and go
the thumb drive and go legacy box take
care it takes care of everything and
they provide updates at every step of
the process my family we sent in some
old films that my dad had of his dad and
we got back from legacy box it's just
fantastic 350,000 families have used
legacy box for a limited time go to
legacy box comm slash pen and you get a
40% discount on your order 40% discount
when you use legacy box comm slash
Bennigan's legacy box comm slash menus
that slash men so they know that we say
you also so you get that 40% off again
the service I think is just
indispensable I think that it
there's no better way to preserve
memories and life is about creating
those memories and preserving them so
make sure that you do so with legacy box
just a fantastic fantastic service again
legacy box comm slash pen and you get
that 40 percent off okay so as I say the
media their agenda is pretty obvious in
the left-wing media and that is to
destroy what they perceive is the
right-wing media by any means necessary
we've talked about how that's happened
via Facebook we've talked about how
that's been happening with regard to
this boycott against Laura Ingraham that
is being fostered and pushed on by
people over at CNN and MSNBC well the
latest iteration of this is the push by
the left against Sinclair broadcasting
so Sinclair is a right-wing company it's
owned by people who are on the right and
our Trump supporters and Sinclair has
brought up 173 local affiliates all over
the country and these local affiliates
all over the country have local news
channels read local news stations fine
great well over the over the last couple
of weeks they have had all of their
local news anchors read the same message
and speak the same message so I'm gonna
play the message and then I won't
explain to you why the left went nuts
over this I am Fox and antonio's Jessica
Headley and I'm Ryan Wolfe our greatest
responsibility is to serve our Treasure
Valley communities the old Paso Las
Cruces communities Eastern Iowa
communities mid Michigan communities we
are extremely proud of the quality
balanced journalism that CBS 4 News
produces plaguing our country the
sharing of biased and false news has
become all too common on social media
more alarming some media outlets publish
the same fake stories without checking
facts first the sharing of biased and
false news has come all too common on
okay so it's a little hard to hear
because the way this is cut it's cut
from Deadspin and the way that it's cut
they are trying to show you how all of
these anchors are saying the same thing
and this supposed to be super nefarious
ooh all the anchors saying the same
thing this means that it's a Trump being
plot to take over the media oh it's from
run scare ah okay so here's what they
actually say they say hi I'm blank
our greatest responsibility is to serve
our local communities where it's truly
proud of the quality balanced journalism
that this station provides but we're
concerned about the troubling trend of
irresponsible one-sided news stories
plaguing our country the sharing of
biased and false news has become all too
common on social media more alarming
some media outlets publish these same
fake stories stories that just aren't
true without checking facts first
unfortunately some members of the media
use their platforms to push their own
personal bias and agenda to control
exactly what people think this is
extremely dangerous to a democracy at
our station it's our responsibility to
pursue and report the truth we
understand truth is neither politically
left nor right our commitment to factual
reporting is the foundation of our
credibility now more than ever
okay so Sinclair had all of their local
news anchors say this message right
does that sound terrible to you was
anything in there anything in there say
we support Trump all news is fake news
was there anything in there about you
shouldn't watch CNN you shouldn't watch
MSNBC because all of its fake news you
shouldn't get the New York Times none of
that is in there right now Jimmy Kim oh
of course the the late-night Pope as guy
Benson likes to call him I issued this
Twitter encyclical he said quote this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy and
of course what he's mocking there is the
line in the in the actual statement by
all the sinclair broadcasting hosts that
all of this is that bad news is
extremely dangerous to democracy but the
left went nuts over this it just shows
that sinclair broadcasting is owned lock
stock and barrel by Trump it's now a
White House outlet and they are forcing
their anchors to save pro-trump things
there's only one problem I just read you
the entire message I just read you the
whole thing okay and there is nothing in
the message that smacks of trumpism
nothing in fact if you had brian Stelter
on CNN or Jake Tapper or anyone else
Anderson Cooper at CNN
read that message people on the right
would assume that that message is a slap
at Trump and a slap at Fox News that
message has no political orientation
whatsoever but the left is firmly
convinced that because Sinclair
Broadcast
is a right-wing outlet that means that
what they were doing here was shilling
for Trump and it just goes to show you
how confirmation bias can really adil
your brain because if you look at that
message and you say this is being spits
it's trumpism being ladled down our
throats forcibly there's no way to avoid
it then you're you're miss reading the
message and you're attributing views to
those anchors that the don't Estelle
listen there are companies I know of
them I've worked for some of them okay
there are companies that have a
particular view on Trump and that
require that you mirror that view on
Trump okay that's bad I don't think
that's a good thing I don't think that
like daily where we have a wide
disparity of opinion with regard to the
president's performance on various and
sundry issues that's the outlet that I
run but number one it's our outlet and
number two that's not what's going on
here I mean there's no evidence that was
happening in sinclair broadcasting
didn't stop the left from going nuts
over it anyway because the left will go
nuts over anything that president
Trump's that President Trump does
speaking of which the left is going nuts
over president Trump because President
Trump is going nuts over the fact that
there is this this vast cadre of illegal
immigrants who have been attempting to
march into the United States so
according to the Washington Examiner
Mexican officials have aided a holy week
caravan of over a thousand migrants
headed to the US border to demand Easter
asylum according to reports mostly
Hondurans they posted celebration videos
on Facebook and chant and we are
migrants we are not criminals we are
workers according to an account from the
Center for Immigration Studies Mexican
authorities have allowed the migrants to
drive north with relative ease
researcher kosher Luna added that the
group of pueblos sinfronteras which aids
immigrants bragged about speeding into
Mexico it said on Monday web Louis
sinfronteras posted a video with the
caption the refugee Caravan knocking
down borders yesterday in effect on
immigration agents cell bans in the post
when they saw us coming the people
celebrate this first small victory
locals have provided supplies along the
way so Trump I think rightly is upset
with the Mexican government for
fostering illegal immigration into the
United States this would be a clear case
where the Mexican government is not
doing its job the Mexican government has
very very stringent border policies on
its southern border unless it thinks
that you're moving right along through
up to the United States in that case
they seem to be perfectly okay with
people crossing the border the border
laws in Mexico are extraordinarily harsh
like if you're an illegal immigrant
Mexico they will deport you
or jail you it is much harsher than the
strictures in the United States so
President Trump started tweeting about
this and of course the left thinks that
he's wrong to even be outraged about
this at all you know I think that
somebody says here is not factually
correct but he's not wrong to be
outraged in Mexico for allowing this to
happen
he says Border Patrol agents are not
allowed to properly do their job at the
border because of ridiculous Liberal
Democrat laws like catch and release
getting more dangerous caravans coming
Republicans must go to nuclear option to
pass tough laws now no more Jack a deal
okay so I agree with the president that
that these caravans have to stop
obviously he's tweeted Mexico is doing
very little if not nothing at stopping
people from flowing into Mexico through
their southern border and then into the
US they left our double immigration laws
they must stop the big drug and people
flows where I will stop their cash cow
NAFTA need wall okay again this is about
half right you know what he says about
the Mexican government doing very little
to stop people from flowing into the
United States is basically correct then
he says these big flows of people are
all trying to take advantage of daca
they want in on the act here's where
there's a hole in Trump's logic and then
the hole is this it was Trump who
decided that he's not going to just
deport all these folks right Trump has
the executive authority already to
deport all of these people he does okay
under current immigration law if he were
to just enforce current immigration law
all these people could be deported daca
is not the state of the law
he's already revoked daca so that really
has nothing to do with this particular
move by people crossing the border
illegally right in fact he already
revoked that program so when he said and
when he says build the wall you know the
president was elected to do just that
right now if he wanted to he could
presumably shift funds from defense
measures over to building the wall along
those lines when he says that he's going
to do something about NAFTA because that
is Mexico's cash cow again I don't
really appreciate that the president's
first move on all this stuff is always
to tariffs his first move as always we
need tariffs and that'll solve all of
our problems you know killing NAFTA
would actually be really bad for a lot
of manufacturers in the United States
but where the media is wrong is when
they're wrong when they suggest the
Trump is is being too harsh with Mexico
on their facilitation of illegal
immigration they are right when they say
that he's obviously not speaking in in
any sort of reasoned language about daca
because again death is on the press
that's an executive policy if Trump
wants to get rid of daca he has every
ability to do so and talk a little bit
more about that in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
brand-new sponsors the folks over the
movie Chappaquiddick now it is a real
pleasure really I'm very excited that
the folks who made Chappaquiddick are
advertising with us because
Chappaquiddick which opens up on in
theaters on April 6th is just a
fantastic movie it's a really really
good movie I've had a chance to screen
it a little bit later in the show I'm
gonna have on one of the producers of
the film so that we can actually talk
about how Chappaquiddick was made
because it's sort of an astonishing
thing it was made in the first place
Chappaquiddick is of course the story of
Ted Kennedy who drove a woman off a
bridge and left her to drown in the car
really she suffocated in the car and the
movie does not soft-pedal this and the
movie is it's not a right-wing screed
okay it doesn't go along with it doesn't
try to go beyond what the evidence shows
so for example there's nothing in the
movie that suggests that that Ted
Kennedy and Mary Jo Kopechne were
clearly having an affair that she was
pregnant because there's no evidence to
support that but it does stick to the
evidence and the evidence is damning
enough it is an amazing thing that this
this film got made and it's amazing
thing that it's getting wide releases
all the performances are universally
great and Ted Kennedy does not come off
well in this movie as well he should not
it is it took 50 years for this movie be
made and it is worth every minute of the
film it is just if you are conservative
and you worry about Hollywood skewing to
the left if you're somebody who said you
know in the last couple of weeks I'm
watching Roseanne because I want to show
Hollywood that my voice counts show
Hollywood your voice counts go see
Chappaquiddick take your family to see
Chappaquiddick it's important to know
how the Democrat machine worked in
Chappaquiddick half the stories about
the Kennedy family
okay the Kennedy family does not come
off well a lot of the stories about the
Democratic infrastructure in law
enforcement in Massachusetts at the time
does not come off well again really
well-written
beautifully filmed beautifully acted and
Chappaquiddick tells the story that the
the left media has wanted to ignore for
50 years remember after Chappaquiddick
ted kennedy still ran for president in
1980 and he almost defeated jimmy carter
the incumbent Ted Kennedy wanted to run
in 1984 it did not end his career okay
this movie shows you why it should have
ended his career indeed he won't you're
not gonna want to miss this story again
Chappaquiddick in theaters everywhere on
April 6th did you almost have a moral
obligation to go see the film okay so I
have a lot more coming up but for that
you're gonna have to subscribe over a
daily wire
common daily wear comm $9.99 a month you
got the rest of the show you get the
rest of Andrew Klavan show the rest of
Michael Noel's his show and when you
subscribe you also get to be part of our
mailbag which we will be doing a little
bit later this week on Friday which
should be should be awesome sauce so
check that out also if you get the
annual subscription to get the tumbler
that I do not have with me because when
I'm traveling I don't I can't I can't
bring it it's just too magnificent I
can't risk it being lost in transit but
you can get it you can get it in the
mail and you can put it next to your bed
you can treasure it you can drink from
its it from them imbibe the glories and
wisdom that flow through it every single
day all you have to do is spend $99 a
year and you get our magnificent travel
mug you get them our magnificent tumbler
check it out the leftist chairs hot or
cold tumbler also also if you subscribe
you get to be part of the conversation
so next Tuesday April 10 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific if you haven't
yet joined the conversation series is
our monthly QA hosted by Alicia Krause
where we answer any and all questions
from politics to the personal and this
month features our very own Andrew
Clavin it streams live at daily wire
YouTube and Facebook but if you want to
ask questions then you have to be a
subscriber so you log into our website
daily wire.com you head over to the
conversation page to watch the live
stream after that you just start typing
into the daily wired chat box and I'll
answer questions as they come in for an
entire hour rather at Clavin will answer
questions as they come in for an entire
hour subscribe to get those questions
answered by drew on Tuesday April 10th
5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific join
the conversation or if you just want to
listen later to the program check out
iTunes or SoundCloud or YouTube please
subscribe please as Willis review it
always helps we are the largest
fastest-growing show and conservative
show in America
[Music]
okay so what President Trump had to say
about the about the daca deal again it
doesn't make a whole hell of a lot of
sense
he's not wrong to be angry about the
situation on the border but this is what
people elected him to stop and he
already has the authority to do it so
when Trump says that he wants to pass
some sort of daca bill solving the deck
a problem doesn't actually solve the
daca problem okay if you have you legal
immigrants crossing the border and
you're not deporting them that has
nothing to do with daca that has to do
with your enforcement regimen so
President Trump owes it to his
supporters who actually deport the
people who are coming across the border
there's actually a great could be a
great moment for him right it was from
talking about mexicans wanting to take
advantage on daca it's a very sad thing
we do Mexico has got to help us at the
border
a lot of people are coming in because
they want to take advantage of daca and
what
really see they had a great chance the
Democrats blew it they had a great great
chance but we'll have to take a look but
Mexico has got to help us at the border
Mexico okay that doesn't make any sense
with regard to jack-up but again the
president does have the authority to
stop this and he's right that it has to
be stopped this could be a good moment
for him to stand up for American
sovereignty and say look just because
people want to enter the country
illegally does not mean that we have to
let people enter the country illegally
okay in other news meanwhile there's a
big turmoil brewing over in Israel where
Palestinian sponsored by Hamas the
terrorist group have decided to try to
walk across the Israeli border or to
break down the physical barrier between
the Gaza Strip and Israel proper and the
media of course are lying about this
entire situation they're suggesting that
Israel is indiscriminately firing into
crowds and trying to kill random people
obviously this is untrue there are tens
of thousands of people who started
camping along that border Israel killed
virtually none of them okay Israel shot
in two crowds of people who are throwing
Molotov cocktails and rolling tires that
were on fire at Israeli soldiers and
throwing stones at those Israeli
soldiers who are attacking Israeli
soldiers how do we know this because
only 15 people have been killed and 10
of the people who have been killed in
that border riot are active members of
terrorist groups active members of
terrorist groups of Israel really
indiscriminately firing into the crowds
then there would be hundreds of people
dead not 15 people dead and if Israel
were really attacking that entire group
of people they'd be using their f-16s to
presumably strafe the tens of thousands
of people who are there not fire in very
discriminative are attempting to break
down the border now the left hates
Israel of course so Bernie Sanders says
he doesn't believe Israel's story
because Bernie Sanders is a rabid
anti-israel extremist no I don't I think
from what my understanding is is you
have tens and tens of thousands of
people who are engaged in a nonviolent
protest I believe now 15 or 20 people
Palestinians have been killed and many
many others have been wounded so I think
it's a difficult situation but my
assessment is that Israel overreacted on
that of course of course that's his
assessment because there's never been an
assessment by Bernie Sanders where
Israel didn't overreact when when
terrorists are firing rockets into the
center of Israel then is
still presumably not overreacting
because it's still overreacting because
Israel's always in the wrong according
to Bernie Sanders because he's a
socialist first rather than a defender
of Western civilization okay here is
according to The Jerusalem Post as the
day wore on hundreds of palestinian
youths ignored calls from the organizers
and the israeli military to stay away
from the frontier
whereas railey soldiers across the
border kept watch from dirt mounds
embankments the military said its troops
had only used live fire against people
trying to sabotage the border security
fence
some of them rolling burning tires and
throwing rocks and that at least two of
the Dead or Hamas operatives it is also
worth noting here how much money did
Hamas spend on this little demonstration
they spent fifteen million dollars on
this demonstration 15 million dollars
right now Hamas is in a state of
complete economic collapse the Gaza
Strip is in a state of complete economic
collapse and yet
Hamas is spending fifteen million
dollars for this protest specifically
because they want to misdirect from the
fact that they are a terrorist group
8:8 like an actual State Department
sponsored terrorist group that is now
sponsoring acts of additional terror
against Israel that is the goal here and
you know Israel ought to be doing a
better job on its PR but again it's
demonstrative of the fact that when it
comes to this particular conflict the
media only seems to care about Israelis
killing Palestinians even if the
Palestinians are terrorists worth noting
that I think in the last month something
like 2530 Palestinians were killed in
Syria over the course of the Syrian
conflict almost 4,000 Syrian
Palestinians living in Syria have been
killed that's been completely unremarked
when muslims kill other Muslims it's not
a news story when Jews kill Muslims it's
a news story when Muslims kill Jews in
Israel is not really a news story it's
amazing how that works and that's
because of the soft bigotry of low
expectations that the media have
attached to Muslims all over the world
so that when Muslims commit violent acts
the media basically ignores it or
pretends that it's the effect of some
sort of some sort of inequality or
nastiness on the part of Western
civilization when in reality Muslims
should be held all over the world to the
same exact moral standards as Jews and
as Christians which is you don't get to
kill people and get away with it unless
you're killing people in self-defense
which is actually what's going on in the
Gaza Strip despite all of the rabidly
anti-israel media coverage no shock
there okay time for some things I like
and then we'll do some things I hate
we'll do a quick Federalist
papers so things that I like today I had
the actually rather on Friday I had the
pleasure of sitting down with one of the
producers for Chaplin because I say the
movie is just spectacular and and here's
what it sounded like when we sat down
together so here we are you have the
opportunity to sit down with Mark
chardee he is the producer of the brand
new flick Chappaquiddick it is a
phenomenal movie I had the opportunity
to screen it a little bit early and Mark
it's it's it's really a fascinating
first of all I have to ask you how did
this thing get done in the first place
I'm sure you're getting this from
everybody on the right how did a movie
about Ted Kennedy leaving a woman to
drown under water yeah I mean we didn't
set out to make a political statement
the move came to me from a friend who's
a manager represented these two young
writers they had heard this word
Chappaquiddick and knew nothing about it
so they started doing research they got
so transfixed that they started to pull
all kinds of material the inquest most
of it was their research and they just
wrote a script they suspect the script
wrote it and my friend sat down and we
had a lunch together and he said hey I
got this script he goes I have no idea
how how Hollywood is gonna you know
respond to this but he said it's really
good so we read it loved it and we
acquired it and then set I mean we had
no idea if we can make it you know
you're obviously gotta get a director
and a star and cast but everyone
responded incredibly well I mean it was
just such a kind of page turning
thriller that in a history lesson as
well it's fascinating did you get any
pushback in town on on making it from
different actors who turned it down yeah
there were a couple actors that really
loved the script it just felt like maybe
was a little tricky you know politically
so we kind of thought like maybe we get
an Australian or or UK director or actor
and and you know Jason Clark he's
Australian and you know it's it's it's a
brave twist but the role is so good and
he's so good in it and if you can
execute was what was on the page we knew
we'd have something and there's so many
great actors in the film from kate mara
who plays Mary Jo Kopechne Ian and does
it with you know just tremendous amount
of sympathy cuz you don't really see it
as a full-fledged character until you
see the film - you have a couple of
comics who are playing kind of the
sidekicks - Ted Kennedy and it really is
an amazing yeah task yeah john curran
who directed it you know with the cast
he felt like because the movies so
serious and you know there's a tragedy
involved that he wanted to have
I wouldn't say lightness but to the
moments when you're in the war room
there there there there's moments of
levity of kind of absurdness and where
Ed Helms and and Jim Gaffigan can kind
of mine those you get laughs in the
movie believe it or not some are
uncomfortable but some are just like
absurd and and when you have that timing
it helps and those guys were tremendous
and Bruce Dern isn't in for five seconds
and he's just really powerful terrific
enough well I think one of the reasons
that the movie is gonna not only do well
I think that the critics will be ok with
it is because you actually stuck really
as much as you could to the facts I mean
there's no rumor mongering in this at
all so as somebody studied this from the
time that I was younger as a
conservative was the big thing right
yeah there's all this speculation about
was Ted Kennedy sleeping with Mary Jo
Kopechne a was she pregnant you know all
the sort of various things that people
speculate because there's so many
unanswered questions but the movie
really sticks to what you know which i
think is one of the strengths of the
film yeah that that was the purpose
going in you know to not take to go
right down the center just tell the
facts and you know it's an indictment no
no doubt you can't get around that but
but I think there's more nuance to the
film and and that was the intent and
yeah critics are responding and people
on both sides of the aisle I mean we did
three screenings in Martha's Vineyard
that were they were incredible and and
people just appreciated that the care we
took with it and you know you brought up
marriage okay Peck knee you know someone
that never had a voice through this
through 50 years their family had
reached out before we made the movie I
had made brief contact and didn't want
to be swayed in any way kind of putting
what we had down you know into the film
and so when the movie was finished we
connected again and we set up a
screening for the family and and they
were incredibly appreciative it was very
difficult to watch obviously but what
they loved is that she's portrayed as
smart and funny and ambitious and and
just you know a real person not just a
picture associated with you know a name
Chappaquiddick and then that entire
sequence of what happens to her is so
heartbreaking and it just really infuses
the rest of the movie because instead of
it just being okay Ted Kennedy's just a
lost little lamb you know with his
family you realize that a person died
and that keeps coming up throughout the
rest of the film obviously that's the
thing you go back and forth with you
know I wouldn't say
any sympathy for Ted but you you know
there's some understanding in an emotion
too to all the characters in it it was a
and so if you you know again have a
little nuance with the film you know it
it'll keep you going both ways he has a
chance to kind of do the right thing and
then he doesn't then he does something
maybe that he should and then he
shouldn't so you kind of go back and
forth through the whole movie no it
really is a tremendous film films
Chappaquiddick and of course we're
talking with producer mark chardee and
and thank him so much for joining us and
I'm excited that the movies even out
there it's a story that has need to be
told for a half a century I mean this it
hey I'll just say this on my own behalf
if this had happened to a Republican
this would've been a movie within 30
seconds of it actually occurring so the
fact that it's a CAF a century for it to
happen about Teddy Kennedy one of the
most famous men in the history of
American politics is pretty incredible
yeah well thank thank you and and you
know would love to have all our
audience's supportive but especially
conservatives you know they talk that
Hollywood never does these good movies
and we do and it's it's not a partisan
movie at all and I think it's enjoyed by
both sides but but certainly
conservative audiences should should
support this I think it's almost a moral
obligation for conservative audiences to
go see this if they're gonna talk about
how much Hollywood is biased they at
least need to go support things that are
not biased in favor of the left another
good salad takes on the facts like a
movie Chappaquiddick thanks so much for
stopping by and everybody go see the
film it's terrific appreciate it okay so
that was a pleasure to sit down with
mark chardee the movie again is
fantastic I cannot recommend it highly
enough and you have an obligation as a
conservative to go see movies that are
not overtly left-wing and that tell the
truth about folks on the left so go out
and see the movie and tell all your
friends to see the movie as well okay
time for some things that I hate so
we've been told that the youth shall
lead us that the youth are the greatest
among lists that the youth are the
wisest among us well I have a story that
puts the lie to this hey there is
something called the teenage snorting
condom fad I am not joking this is a
real actual thing according to the
Sacramento Bee it sounds like an April
Fool's joke but educators are warning
about a condom challenge being spread
online by YouTube videos in social media
also known as the snorting condom
challenge or condom snorting challenge
the Fed actually dates back several
years but recently has gone viral again
educators say now you ask yourself hey
listen back when I was a teenager it was
just cocaine but no now there
snorting actual physical objects that
have mass and size up their nose why
because no one really understands so the
challenge involves according to the
Sacramento Bee snorting an unwrapped
prophylactic up one nostril then pulling
it out from the throat through the mouth
according to a Newsweek story
participants then post a video of the
completed challenge to YouTube and the
challenge has gone viral okay it is not
new this first apparently started with
YouTube star Savannah's strong in 2013
apparently YouTube has been moving these
these stories and videos for a long
while but it is not a good idea it turns
out because you could number one choke
on it and also because you are putting a
condom up your nose you idiots what
could you possibly be thinking why are
you stupid okay this is the same
generation we had just warned against
eating Tide Pods which is an actual
cleaning product okay so don't eat Tide
Pods and also don't put condoms up your
nose comprehensive sex ed is just not
going the way that people on the Left
thought it was going to go you know when
they were breaking out that the
prophylactics of the bananas back in
third grade they figured that they were
trying to explain one thing it turns out
that people are just trying to figure
out a way that they could get the condom
into facial bodily orifices it's just
what in the world and these are the
people these are the youth shall lead
them again this is not to say the young
people can't have some interesting
things to say but interesting sometimes
means stupid apparently and also when
you're young okay just in terms of brain
development your brain does not really
stop developing interment reach its full
developmental stage until you're about
25 26 years old when you are 17 16 15
years old you are the kind of person who
does dumb stuff like this because you
have an amygdala which is your emotional
response Center which is doing virtually
all the heavy lifting in your prefrontal
cortex is underdeveloped as compared to
your amygdala so that means you do lots
of dumb crap when you're a teenager you
a lot of dumb stuff when you're a
teenager and yet the left is now saying
why don't we lower the voting age to 16
why don't we suggest that 12 year olds
can get an abortion without parental
consent why don't we say that 3 year
olds can change their gender you know
just because they're 3 I mean come on
they're the most innocent and beautiful
among us why should we put our societal
values on them because you're an adult
and kids are kids and I'm speaking as
someone who's a syndicated columnist at
age 17 I didn't know as much stuff at 17
as I do now my self-control
not as great at 17 as it is now and I
had pretty good self control when I was
17 and still I have had more
self-control now than men so before we
hear all about how the youth Shelley
does perhaps they should learn where
particular where particular
prophylactics are designed to be used
okay it's not the nose what in the world
so good job everybody
speaking of people who appear to have
snorted at a condom and left it just in
their brain embedded there Chelsea
Handler tweeted something out really
insane about the Second Amendment the
other day here's what it looked like she
threw out my arm guards aren't killing
children and don't have semi-automatic
weapons because she was asked about
being ignorant of the Constitution and
not knowing anything about how the
Constitution works so somebody tweeted
get rid of your armed guards and then
you can talk to the middle class about
feeling safe and should my armed guards
aren't killing children and don't have
semi-automatic weapons okay first of all
I would guarantee that her armed guards
have semi-automatic weapons and she
doesn't notice em my automatic weapon is
that's number one because every armed
guard I've ever worked with has the
semi-automatic weapon you know why
because virtually every pistol in the
United States is a semiautomatic weapon
unless they're carrying a revolver
unless they're carrying like an
old-style Dirty Harry colt 45 it's a
semi-automatic weapon second of all
guess who else isn't killing children
anyone else who has a semi-automatic
weapon in the United States and is not
the shooter in parklands and so it's all
fun and games for Chelsea Handler
because I guess only her armed guards
are apparently the only people in the
United States who have some amount of
matic weapons we're not murdering
children apparently the amazing I mean
good for her that she found the five
guys in America with semi-automatic
weapons who aren't shooting children
what an emit what an amazing feat it's
not that there are millions of Americans
who own semi-automatic weapons and use
them to defend their children and not to
shoot children no it's that Chelsea
Handler's people are just the best
people they're just the best people I
and then they wonder why we don't trust
them on Second Amendment issues they
won't when when they've got spokespeople
like Chelsea Handler and condoms condoms
snorting teenagers not to suggest the
kids at Parkland are doing that but
there are but again the youth of America
there's some questions to be asked
that's all I'm saying okay so Federalist
paper so every week we go through a
federalist paper we're now up to
Federalist 22 Alexander Hamilton wrote
Federalist number 22 and this Federalist
paper continues with the flaws of the
current the Articles of Confederation
that was replaced by the Constitution of
the United States he
several criticisms of the Articles of
Confederation in this particular in this
particular Federalist paper first he
says we need a system that does not
allow internal tariffs or allow various
parts of the country to refute to a
refuse to abide by foreign tariff rules
so in other words you need a federal
government that can set tariff policy be
and and you can't have states that
override it otherwise none of the tariff
policies that you actually impose are
going to be workable if you work a deal
with Great Britain to lower your trade
barriers and then South Carolina says
we're gonna set up our own tariffs well
then why exactly would Britain negotiate
with the United States as opposed to
just negotiating with each individual
state thereby separating them off from
the mother country cases also under the
Articles of Confederation the way that
the army was summoned was by going to
particular States and requesting that
they send men this actually did not work
well during the American Revolution and
he says this actually created the system
of bidding or particular States knowing
they had to submit a certain number of
men would actually just put out a price
a wage price for particular soldiers and
people would leave their home state and
go to the other state because they knew
that they were going to be able to be
called up there and get paid a higher
price also Hamilton says that we can't
have a system of that's completely like
the US Senate where it's equal
representation for every state and then
a two-thirds majority to decide things
because then nothing will get done
instead he says that we need a majority
at least one house that's House of
Representatives where population is
represented in the number of
Representatives and then finally he
suggests that we also need a judiciary
capable of interpreting the laws and
treaties and he says that if we don't
have a judiciary that is going to
interpret those laws and treaties from
the federal level then again that allows
state courts to basically stand as an
obstacle to federal policy the most
important thing that happens in this
Federalist paper Federalist 22 is what
he says at the very end what he says
that the the Constitution of the United
States is to be approved by the people
themselves that is why we the people is
the beginning of the Constitution of the
United States and the reason for that
and the reason this is important is
because one of the arguments in the
Civil War was that once the federal
government had violated the sovereignty
of particular States those states were
signatories to the Constitution and
therefore they no longer had to abide by
it right through the contract against
the states had been violated and so
states had the ability and the right to
pull out that is what they called
compact theory that the Constitution was
a compact between the states it was not
actually a compact
the people Hamilton for seeing this
problem in 1789 is already writing about
he says the possibility of a question of
this nature proves the necessity of
laying the foundations of our national
government deeper than in the mirror
sanction of delegated authority the
fabric of American Empire ought to rest
on the solid basis of the consent of the
people all caps the streams of national
power ought to flow immediately from
that pure original fountain of all
legitimate Authority so this is why
there were specific constitutional
conventions called in each state in
order to approve the Constitution right
the idea here was that it was the people
themselves who were going to approve the
Constitution and so the compact of the
Constitution is between all of the
people not just the various states who
have their various interests at play
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow with
all of the latest news I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018